more bad
news almost all communication today is
round white and
flavorless in other words all
communication today all the words spoken
all the words written and emails and
documents things you speak in conference
rooms sales pitches marketing strategies
branding all of it it's round white and
flavorless which is to say it sounds
just like everything that everyone else
is saying it's pretty ridiculous that
people attempt to write and speak in the
way that everyone else is writing and
speaking that is
outrageous and foolish and non-effective
non-effective is that a word I don't
know if it's a word but I'm thrilled by
it because it's not round white and
flavorless non-effective is not a word
but you will remember it
so it is
non-effective what we're seeking to do
what you're seeking to do what I want
you to be seeking to do I want you to be
seeking the opposite of round white and
flavorless I want the things that you
say to have color and Edge I want them
to feel visceral in the audience's mind
I want you to speak and write in a way
that is different than everyone else I
want you to look at the way people are
writing and speaking and say to yourself
I'm not going to do that because if I do
I'm going to be round white and
flavorless in other words just like
everyone else so as we move forward
through this course I'm going to be
talking about things that you can do to
differentiate yourself to make your
communication your storytelling
different than everyone else this should
be the goal it's also going to be an un
comfortable goal for many people round
white and flavorless is also safe when
you sound like everyone else there is no
danger you're not in danger of standing
out you're not in danger of sticking out
like a sore thumb you're not in danger
of being the dandelion on the beautiful
manicured grass but here's the thing if
you are a single blade of grass on a
beautiful manicured lawn you are not
noticed you are round white and
flavorless you're green but you might as
well be round white and flavorless I
want you to be the dandelion I want you
to be the outrageous ridiculous
dandelion on the perfectly manicured
lawn that is your goal as we move
forward in this course I'm going to ask
you to stop being round white and
flavorless it's going to be hard it's
going to be challenging it's going to be
scary but it's what you must do